welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
moss and the matrix is getting read
something for a fourth film with Keanu
Reeves and carrie-anne moss returning
and lana wachowski writing and directing
and I'm sure Keanu being mr.
breathtaking 2019 and all of us suddenly
being obsessed with him again has
nothing to do with it
production for this film is set to begin
in early 2020 which could lead to like a
summer 2021 release and while the script
sounds like it is done the movie's plot
remains a mystery I have had matrix on
the brain ever since I read pulled
myself for my recent in-depth rewatched
of the first film go check that out but
here I'm gonna break down everything we
know about this new matrix film how
things were left after reloaded and
revolutions to set the stage for another
film and whether this sequel is just
pure studio cash-grab or a critical
reflection of society today or let's be
honest made about spoiler warning in
case I accidentally predict anything
about this movie that lessens your
enjoyment
okay so first quick refresher on how
reloaded and revolutions ended the
climax of the Matrix Reloaded so neo
meeting with the architects remember
that heart-stopping thrill ride of cold
muted exposition the architect explained
to neo that he was in the sixth of
multiple iterations of the matrix a
cycle with neo as these systems inherent
anomaly causing chaos and rebellion to
threaten the matrix as existence with
that very rebellion itself coded into
the system by the architect and the
Oracle leading to an event allottee that
this anomaly would face the choice to
save and reboot the matrix with a select
group of freed humans in Zion and start
the cycle anew or
let this whole system crash killing
everyone inside the past five anomalies
decided to reboot restore restart the
cycle but neo 6.0 decided I love Trinity
and I want to be with her let it all
burn and that leads us to the Matrix
Revolutions
as machines lay siege to Zion neo and
Trinity surface up top at the desert of
the real
headed to machine city but Trinity dies
in the most awkwardly times death reveal
ever one
leo it's a brokering a truce with the
machines I'll help you rid yourself of
Agent Smith virus and has overtaken her
system in exchange for peace in the war
between man and machine
so no more cycle of anomalies rebellion
and resetting this time a system where
both humans and machines can coexist
peacefully so the machines plug neo back
in where he confronts thousands of agent
Smith's in a Super Saiyan rain battle
and in the end neo let smith assimilate
into him knowing that Smith is a
compulsive AI driven by purpose and has
no choice but to assimilate Anna Smith
does this neo makes it so that the
machines kill his corporeal body
therefore also destroying the Smith
virus Christ pose sacrificed to save the
world love is the answer yada yada yada
so revolutions ends ambiguously watching
this sunrise on a seventh iteration of
the matrix insert your own seventh day
God created the universe metaphor
there's a little kid there the humans
and machines have brokered a peace a
peace that might not last forever they
say but at least in this new matrix
humans will be given the choice to be
free or to be enslaved some like me
would probably be like cypher and
decided to eat delicious steak and
blissful ignorance whereas others would
prefer their cave orgies
but with neo and Trinity dead where does
this leave a fourth Matrix film starring
Keanu Reeves the carrie-anne moss well I
have a theory I'll go into it well
before you continue thank you to our
sponsor recon for helping us make this
episode recon that makes sleek
comfortable wireless headphones that are
way more affordable than the other
options out there and I wasted way too
much time with corded headphones it's
getting caught and low-hanging tree
limbs and airplane seat armrests
Mitchell is just getting tangled up like
quietly freaking coyote but these rake
on wireless earbuds super discreet you
just pair them with your device and then
you simply pop them in like that and
then you're good to listen to whatever
music or podcasts you want and you can
feel like cardi B who is also obsessed
with these I have so much to come in
with her raid cons a 50 wireless earbuds
look stylish you feel comfortably sound
amazing and rake ons everybod start
about half the price of any other
premium wireless earbuds on the market
so click on the link in the description
below to get 15% off your order okay
back to my theory for how they
bring back neo and Trinity and matrix
for this next film could be set in a
future iteration of the matrix either
this seventh one that we saw the end of
revolutions or some later one in which
neo and Trinity had been rebooted
actually now I think of it Matrix
rebooted or like matrix resurrected
wouldn't be the worst titles but we do
know from the architects scene that past
anomalies looked exactly like neo so
presumably a future generation of this
anomaly would still look like Keanu
Reeves who let's be honest is every bit
as breathtaking as he was twenty years
ago
each new iteration of the matrix
addresses flaws in the previous system
so maybe the peace between humans and
machines has ended and a kind of covert
cold war in which the sides are unaware
of the ways that the other side are
continuing to subvert and hack each
other like maybe we'll see a seemingly
freed human society secretly infiltrated
by sleeper cell machine controlled
humans kind of like how Smith operated
Bane with the aim to control all of
humanity once more and it could be the
task of the relic of the previous
anomalies system to decode this mystery
a plot Madame like goes to the shell
which was the primary influence of the
Wachowski cyberpunk concepts but this
brings up the question of how central
Rives and moss will be to this cast as
well as people like Laurence Fishburne
and Hugo Weaving who are still busy
beloved actors who could return in the
sequel as well so would this fourth
Matrix film make neo the hero of the
story once again or the way JJ Abrams
did with the force awakens feature the
old cast as supporting characters to a
new generation of heroes and villains
well really the latter might not be the
worst way to go neo in Trinity in this
new matrix could be the old timers with
memory flashes to pass lives that they
don't really understand but they end up
having to play some pivotal role in a
new mystery or conflict led by a younger
generation of characters eventually
solve something like this with Blade
Runner 2049 which huh also like the
force awakens featured Harrison Ford is
a grizzled version of his classic
character mentoring a younger smartass
and you know come to think of it they
did the same thing with Ford and Indiana
Jones Kingdom of the Crystal Skull as
opposed Harrison Ford is the cyclical
anomaly of generational reboots lana
wachowski has said only this about the
movie's plot many of the ideas lily and
I explored 20 years ago about our
reality are even more relevant now
makes you wonder what theme she's
referring to of course there's the whole
idea of propaganda fake news simulated
realities the rise of conspiracy theory
thinking into the mainstream and how a
society can function when no one can
trust any authority perhaps this new
matrix could explore controlling systems
on a subtler scale with the machines
trying to lure humanity back into
enslavement with the promise of VR
escapism entertainment gaming porn
YouTube break downs there's also the
theme of gender identity something Corte
double cows keys lives and a theme that
they wanted to include in the first
matrix film with a character of switch
switch was originally conceived to be
male outside of the matrix but then
switched to female inside the matrix to
reflect her true identity perhaps this
new matrix film will finally allow lana
wachowski to explore that concept
through a new character the matrix
remains one of my all-time favorite
films and I don't think reload and
revolutions are given enough credit so I
am excited to see how this next chapter
applies cyberpunk philosophy to the
modern era and maybe also we'll get a
chance to dig into the lingering
theories from the original trilogy like
is the real world also a simulation and
is Agent Smith actually the one and are
my matrix short films that I shot when I
was 12 years old considered canon I
think so what story do you want this
next Matrix film to focus on comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on twitter and instagram at a vas and
subscribe to new rockstars for more
breakdowns of theories about everything
you love thank you for joining me and
let's be honest matrix 4 is just gonna
be cyberpunk 2077 right
[Music]